Hi everyone my name is Josh and I'm a user experience sign up working on Burp Suite Professional.
I'm here today to show you some changes that were made to the proxy incept which should hopefully make your workflow faster and more efficient.
Let's take a look.
So if I jump straight in you can see that incept is off by default so I'll turn this on.
I'll open Burp's browser and browse to a website.
Then heading back to Burp you can see that I now have my request queued in the table.
And I can edit this request in the editor below.
Once I forward this on you can see that my responses will also show in the table and I can easily see the corresponding request.
I can select the ones I'm interested in and forward them on individually or in a group.
I still have the ability to add a highlight and notes to request.
And you can see that these still carry across to the proxy history.
I can also change the forward button to a forward all for an easy way to clear the queue.
And when I'm done I simply turn intercept off.
So hopefully these changes will make your workflow faster and more efficient and we'd love to hear any feedback that you have.
Cheers.